What are you doing here?
Let me in.
Alex, because she
is Mitch’s equal,
she is a white
woman of privilege,
she has experienced
a certain kind of Mitch
and so, she’s really
trying to wrestle with
her experience of Mitch and who
she knows him to be with
other women’s
experiences of him.
I wanna be better!
I wanna be a
better person, please!
Just no,
seriously Alex!
I just, I want
to be a good person!
As human beings
we are fallible, we are
capable of horrible things.
We are capable of
wonderful things.
And we don’t make
enough room in this moment
for contrition,
to be able to say sorry,
to mean it, to move on.
We’re dealing with it in the
best way we can on the show
cause I think it’s
really important
cause that is the big question.
Is there redemption for anyone?
And he’s trying
to understand.
He really wants to do better.
It’s just time for me to go,
we were quarantining.
I know that you don’t
actually want to leave,
so could we just
stop with the pretending?
Valeria Golino
Ugh! She’s so incredible.
She’s one of the
most free, wonderful
ators I’ve ever worked with.
She’s just not
afraid of anything
and her character represents
someone who
has no judgement on Mitch
Yes he has a past
but she accepts him
for who he is.
Valeria understood it all
immediately,
ya know. And there’s
an irreverence to her,
and a kind of daring to her as a
performer that Paola needed
and we saw it right away.
[whispering]
[laughing]
I’m on a mission, I’m on a
mission, I’m on a mission!
Our writers always knew
that Mitch would pass
away this season.
One of the things that we
talked about is how,
when someone passes
the story about them can shift.
And it was very interesting and
rich territory to explore
how people would feel not just
about Mitch when he was living
but how they would feel
about him when he passed.
We ask
who we are as people when
we’ve done horrible things.
Are we still a human being,
or are we a monster?
That’s not for us to answer.
It’s for the audience to answer.